just firstly I started off with a
situation in Dover when I spoke to the
Home Secretary earlier and we've seen
those cues of course the CEO of the port
saying that one of the issues is that
post brexit you have to check everyone's
passport Sue Ella Brotherman said that
actually I don't think it's fair to say
that this is an adverse effect of brexit
who's right
well actually I think the problem is
that we haven't had a government that is
planned for what was going to happen
post-brexit there are clearly a range of
factors that have gone into the delays
here and we've seen them before but the
government has known for a very long
time that they needed to make sure that
there were resources in place to deal
with additional paperwork checks the
point is not whether we left the
European Union or not the point was that
we left with a government that made big
promises and once again didn't deliver
and I really feel for the families that
are trying to get away for a Easter
break people who've been caught up in
this chaos people whose livelihoods are
threatened it didn't need to be this way
and if the government got a grip got
down to Brass attacks and started doing
their actual job all these things could
be avoided
uh one of the other things that we spoke
about in the interview was the new
policy to try and consult on mandatory
reporting where people might have a fear
that child sexual exploitation is taking
place now with an interview the Home
Secretary said that she felt it was one
of the biggest scandals that we've seen
in her words vulnerable White English
girls being pursued and raped and
drugged and harmed by gangs of British
Pakistani men and that people have
turned to Blind Eye due to political
correctness
do you think she's right
look I think we're the Home Secretary
needs to get real we're failing young
people in this country online in on our
streets and in their homes because the
government is just simply not taking it
seriously 20 years ago I was working
with children who were being groomed by
criminal gangs for the children's
Society trying to help them Escape that
there were huge problems with the courts
at the time and them having to give
evidence in person there were there were
some delays in the court system that
made it difficult for them to get access
to Justice we'd call for mandatory
reporting for 20 years so that
professionals working with children and
young people knew that they were under a
duty to report on the behavior of not
just other people but of their own
colleagues if they suspected that there
was a problem and here we are after 13
years of Tory government and finally the
Home Secretary has just woken up and
said let's let's do something about it
and all we've got is a consultation that
is not the mark of a serious government
they must honestly think that we are
fools if they think that we're going to
fall for this as a sign that the
government is taking seriously what is a
huge Scandal and an absolute disgrace
for some of the most vulnerable young
people in this country I think everyone
would agree um about the scandal of
these young girls not being listened to
um appalling but is she right to talk
about the racial profile at some of
these gangs when obviously grooming
gangs sadly happen across all cultures
it's true that they do happen across all
cultures there were when I was working
with children and young people there
were particular issues with
um Kurdish and Pakistani gangs in some
parts of the country there are also huge
issues with white men grooming young
girls online and there were also
problems with boys as well let's not
forget that boys don't escape from these
problems it's just that often what
happens is that they go even more
unreported and unrecognized than girls I
think the problem with what the Home
Secretary is trying to do is that she's
trying to single out one particular
profile and one particular group and the
risk is that if you do that you miss the
fact that there is child abuse going on
in plain sight in homes on the streets
and online and we ought to surely be
aiming to keep all young people safe
from the harm that is created not just
singling out some young people and and
highlighting those forms of abuse and
discrimination this is a government that
just hasn't taken that seriously for 13
years so you'll excuse me if I'm
skeptical about Home Secretary who
suddenly pops up with a press release
just a few months away potentially from
a general election
few months away from a general election
do you know something that I don't well
I mean when whenever the general
election comes we'll be ready for it but
okay honestly I mean if you look at the
failure of this government to preside
over the huge backlogs in the courts at
the moment she's talking about young
people being prevented from being harmed
and getting access to justice but the
courts have come to a standstill because
people can't get through them and
they've presided over chaos the online
harms bill has been dragging on through
the House of Commons with no sense of
urgency I would say to the Home
Secretary stop with the press releases
start rolling up your sleeves and doing
your actual job okay now labor is
calling on the government to freeze
council tax
um you are saying that you're going to
pay for it through a whimful tax it
feels a little bit like as if the
windfall tax is magically solving all of
Labor's problems at the minute when we
all know that of course the amount of
money the amount of Revenue you get from
a windfall tax fluctuates massively
depending on the price of oil and gas
which is already starting to level out
you can't rely on it can use a steady
stream of income to fix every possible
economic problem that's going to come
your way
no of course not but we calculate that
the windfall tax could raise around 10
billion pounds the cost of freezing
prices this year would cost
but but right now if you were to do what
we were asking the government to do to
cancel the investment allowances to
raise the level of the windfall tax and
to back date it to when we first called
for it you could raise about 10 billion
pounds now if you raised about 10
billion pounds you could easily use
about 2.92 billion of that to freeze
council tax this year I recognize that
this is not a long-term solution to the
problems that councils face to do that
we need wholesale transformation of the
way that councils and communities are
funded in this country but right now
people's food bills are going up the
housing bills are going up their energy
bills are going up and their taxes are
about to go up as well because the
government is asking councils to put up
council tax by five percent we think
that that is just wrong a time when
people are struggling and that we should
use some of the money from the profits
that big companies are making in order
to ease the pain for people this April
I just feel like I'm talking about the
windfall tax because I feel like every
interview we end up talking about the
windfall tax and I accept it's a popular
policy but it is just one policy that
was announced over a year ago what's the
biggest policy that labor has announced
since the whimple tax
well I mean we've announced for example
that we want 70 of
um of people to be able to realize their
Ambitions of home ownership we announced
that at a conference last year and
through a system of state-backed
mortgage insurance and Rachel Reeves and
I have been working with the big lenders
in order to make that a reality I think
you know policies like solving the
housing crisis introducing breakfast
clubs and crisis so is it that's an
ambition
it's an ambition that we intend to
deliver we'll set ourselves a Target in
government to do so and we'll deliver on
it we've said
um just earlier this month that we want
to achieve the highest sustained growth
in the G7 driven by people in all parts
of Britain and we're working across the
board with businesses and Council
leaders and investors in order to make
that a reality because we know in the
end that windfall tax a windfall tax
will be a fairer way of funding things
right now but none of this can
compensate for 13 years of low or no
growth in this country if you want
really good Public Services if you want
choices and chances for our kids in
every part of the country you've got to
get the economy growing and I make no
apology for saying that that's why labor
has made that absolutely Central to our
program for government